europa tut so staunt jedes mal wenn er
über die real tor brücke läuft
was ist vom charme dieser stadt
geblieben die jedes jahr von millionen
von touristen überlaufen wird
wie kann sich venedig vor diesem
besucheransturm schützen als fotokulisse
allein kann dieses kulturerbe nicht
überleben davon bis paul überzeugt der
liebe für diese stadt wegen suche ich
orte und menschen welche venedig noch am
leben erhalten
denn es gibt genügend leute die gegen
steuern die diese stadt wieder in ein
neues fahrwasser bringen wollen
paulus selbst lebt vom tourismus die
fast alle venezianer das ist sein
dilemma mit besonderen stadtführungen
welle auf die probleme aufmerksam machen
wie in seinem stadtteil wo die mieten
steigen wegen der vielen ferienwohnungen
wo immer mehr einheimische weg sich in
seiner stammkneipe ist der niedergang
benedix und das aussterben der
venezianer das große thema vor 20 jahren
wimmelte es hier noch von handwerkern
da wurde noch produziert für die
bevölkerung polsterer schreiner
schlosser
ich bin da alles ist verschwunden heute
macht niemand mehr matratzen präpariert
keiner mehr schuhe
das klingt den stolz der venezianer was
ist übrig von ihrer einzureichen
handelsmetropole paulo zeigt den alten
fisch und gemüse markt auch er ist nur
noch reine touristen attrappe in einer
stadt in der immer weniger menschen
wohnen und wirklich leben
es gibt hier mehr touristen die
fotografieren als kunden die einkaufen
das provoziert und deshalb überlegen
einige fischverkäufer sich jetzt als
statisten als schauspieler in einer
tourismus kulisse bezahlen zu lassen
zum gigantischen problem werden auch die
kreuzfahrtschiffe
stefano micheletti ist schockiert denn
seit jahren laden die riesen nicht nur
massen von tagestouristen ab sondern
bedrohen die fundamente der lagunenstadt
die großen schiffsschrauben haben einen
kolben effekt wühlen dem gesamten
untergrund auf lehm und schlamm werden
so nach und nach aus der lagune ins
offene meer gespült die folge venedig
das auf holzpfählen gebaut ist sagt
immer mehr ab und könnte irgendwann ganz
im wasser versinken
stefano micheletti gibt sich nicht
geschlagen seine bürgerinitiative hat es
geschafft dass nicht noch mehr
kreuzfahrtschiffe die stadt an fahren
dürfen
ballaballa wenn so ein schiff
vorbeifährt sinkt in den umliegenden
kanälen das wasser jeweils um 20
zentimeter und steigt danach wieder
wegen der verdrängung
das sind enorme kräfte die natürlich an
den fundamenten der paläste kirchen und
brücken in venedig nagen
mit seinem engagement schafft sich
stefano micheletti nicht nur freunde
denn venedig hafenbehörde hat millionen
in moderne kreuzfahrtterminals
investiert aufgrund der proteste der
bevölkerung kann sie jetzt aber nur die
hälfte benutzen
seit vier jahren hören wir diese ängste
dass unsere schiffe venedig sogar rahmen
könnten
ich kann nur immer wieder versichern
auch mit dem größten kreuzfahrtschiff
ist dieses risiko gleich null
so wird die kreuzfahrtindustrie
weiterhin für die fahrt vorbei an san
marco als weltweit einzigartig und
verdient daran millionen
doch die front gegen die
kreuzfahrtschiffe wächst auch wegen der
abgase die aus den schornsteinen dampfen
immer mehr venezianer zweifeln ob der
derzeitige kurs ihrer stadt der richtige
ist
die großen bauvorhaben werden bislang
von der flughafen und der
hafengesellschaft entschieden
da geht es nur um wachstum immer mehr
immer größer für das wohlergehen der
stadt fehlt jedoch jede strategie paolo
pato zu macht das traurig und wütend
55.000 einwohner werden jedes jahr von
30 millionen touristen überrollt dafür
braucht es radikale gegenstrategien
es ist paradox aber der beste tour ist
für venedig ist der der nicht in die
stadt kommt wir sind mehr als voll mit
30 millionen besuchern im jahr
pauli glaubt dass der tourismus in
venedig wieder in normale dimensionen
gelenkt werden muss dazu müssten alle
venezianer auf einen teil des großen
geschäfts verzichten um ihre stadt zu
retten